after being done with glycolysis and the
Krebs cycle we're left with 10 nadh --is
10 nadh is and 2 fadh2s and i told you
that these are going to be used in the
electron transport chain and they're all
sitting in the matrix of our
mitochondria and i said they're going to
be used in the electron transport chain
in order to actually generate ATP so
that's what I'm going to focus on in
this video the electron electron
transport transport chain and just so
you know you know a lot of this stuff is
is known but some of the details are
actually current areas of research
people have models and they're trying to
substantiate the models but that things
are happening it's such a small scale
here that people can just look at the
evidence some of it of which is indirect
and say this is probably what's
happening most of this is very
well-established but some of the exact
mechanisms of for example how exactly
some of the proteins work aren't
completely understood so I think it's
very important for you to understand
that this is kind of at the cutting edge
you're already there so the basic idea
here is that the NADH is and that's
where I'll focus fadh2 is kind of the
same idea although its electrons are the
slightly lower energy state so they
won't produce quite as many ATP's each
NADH maybe I'll write it here each NADH
each NADH is going to be as you'll see
indirectly responsible for the
production of three ATP's and each fadh2
in a very efficient cell in both of
these cases will be indirectly
responsible for the production of two
ATP's and the reason why this guy
produces fewer ATP's is because the
electrons that he has going into the
electron transport chain are at a
slightly lower energy level than the
ones from NADH so in general I just said
indirectly how does this whole business
work well in general NADH when it gets
oxidized so na d H remember oxidation is
the losing of electron
the losing of hydrogen's that happen to
have electrons we can write it's half
reaction like this its oxidation
reaction like this you'll have some NAD+
which you can then go and use back in
the Krebs cycle and in glycolysis you
have some nad plus you'll have a proton
right a positive hydrogen ion is just a
proton and then you'll have two
electrons this is the oxidation of NADH
oxidation of NADH it's losing these two
electrons oxidation is losing electrons
oil-rig oxidation is losing electrons or
you can imagine it's losing hydrogens
from which it can hog electrons either
one of those is the case now this is
really the first step of the electron
transport chain these electrons are
transported out of the NADH now the last
step of the electron transport chain is
you have two electrons and you could
view it as the same two electrons if you
like two electrons plus two hydrogen
protons and obviously if you just add
these two together you're just going to
have two hydrogen atoms which is just a
proton and electron plus one oxygen atom
so I could say 1/2 of molecular oxygen
that's the same thing as saying one
oxygen atom and you're going to produce
if I have one oxygen in two complete
hydrogen's I'm left with water I'm left
with water and you could view this we're
adding electrons or we're gaining
electrons to oxygen oil-rig reduction is
gaining electrons so this is the
reduction reduction of oxygen to water
this is the oxidation of NADH to NAD+
now these electrons that are popping out
of these electrons right here that are
popping out of this NADH and it when
they're in NADH they're at a very high
energy state and what happens over the
course of the electron transport chain
is that these electrons get transported
to a series of I guess you could call
them transition molecules but these
transition molecules as the electrons go
from one to the other they go into
slightly lower energy states and I won't
even go into the
details of these molecules when is
coenzyme q and your cytochrome c
cytochrome c and then they eventually
end up right here and they're used to
reduce to reduce your oxygen into water
now every time an electron goes from a
higher energy state to a lower energy
state and that's what it's doing over
the course of this electron transport
chain it's releasing energy it's
releasing energy it's releasing energy
so energy is released when you go from a
higher state to a lower state when these
electrons were in NADH they were in a
higher state than they are when they
bond to coenzyme q so they release
energy then they go to cytochrome c
release energy now that energy is used
to pump protons across the cristae
across the inner membrane of the
mitochondrion this is all very
complicated sounding and you know this
is the cutting edge this is the cutting
edge so it maybe should sound a little
complicated so let me let me draw a
mitochondria so let me draw a small
mitochondria just so you know where
we're operating that it's that's its
outer membrane and then its inner
membrane or its crista would look like
that maybe it looks just like that and
let me zoom in on the membrane so let's
say if I were to take if I were to zoom
in right there so if I were to zoom that
out that box would look like this you
have your crista here now I'm going to
draw it thick right so I'm zooming in
this green line right here I'm going to
draw it really thick I'm going to color
it in with green just like that and then
you have your outer membrane this outer
membrane I can do it up here and I'll
just color it in you don't have to see
the outside of the outer membrane right
here this space right here this is the
outer compartment outer compartment and
then we learned in the last video this
space right here is the matrix this is
the matrix this is where our Krebs cycle
occurred and where a lot of our NADH are
really all of our NADH is sitting so
what happens is is every time NADH gets
oxidized to nad plus or each of the and
the electrons keep transferring from one
to another it's occurring in these big
protein complexes and I'm not going to
the details on this so each of these
protein complexes span span so let's say
that's the protein complex where this
first oxidation reaction is occurring
and releasing energy and then let's say
there's another protein complex here
where the second oxidation reaction is
occurring and releasing energy and these
proteins are able to use that energy to
essentially pump this it might not all
seem very complicated to essentially
pump hydrogen's into the outer membrane
it actually pumps hydrogen protons and
let me be very clear hydrogen protons
into into the outer membrane and every
one of these reactions pump out a
certain number of hydrogen protons so by
the end of the electron transport chain
or you know we just followed one set of
electrons by the time that they've gone
from their high energy state and NADH to
their lower energy State in water by the
time they've done that they've supplied
the energy to these protein complexes
that span our cristae to pump hydrogen
into from the matrix into the outer
membrane so really the only byproduct of
the oxidation of NADH into eventually
water or the oxidation of NADH and the
reduction of oxygen into water isn't
ATP's yet it's just this gradient where
we have a lot higher hydrogen proton
concentration in the outer in the outer
compartment than we do in the matrix or
you could say that the outer compartment
becomes a lot more acidic remember
acidity is just hydrogen proton
concentration the concentration of
hydrogen protons so the byproduct of
this all of this energy is used to
really just pump these protons into the
outer membrane so you have two things
the outer membrane becomes more acidic
than the matrix inside maybe we could
call that basic and obviously these are
all positively charged particles so
there's actually a there's actually a an
electric gradient electric potential
between the outer membrane and the inner
membrane this becomes slightly negative
that becomes slightly positive
these guys wouldn't naturally do this on
their own if this is already acidic and
it's already positive left to its own
devices these more protons wouldn't be
entering and the energy to do that is
supplied by electrons going from high
energy state and NADH to going to a
lower energy state eventually on the
oxygen in the water that's what's
happening but essentially all this
happening is protons being pumped from
the matrix into the outer compartment
now once that gradient forms these guys
want to get back in these guys want to
get back in to the matrix and that is
where the ATP's are formed so there's a
protein that also spans this let me draw
so remember this is all this inner
membrane right here let me just draw it
a little bit bigger right here so that's
our inner membrane our cristae right
there there's a special protein called
and I'll show you actually what it well
a better diagram of what it looks like
in a second called ATP synthase ATP ATP
synthase and what happens is remember
because of the electron transport chain
we have all of these hydrogen ions up
here
all of these protons really all they are
is a proton that really want to get back
into into the matrix down here they
really want to get back down into the
matrix but they can't this cristae is
impermeable to them so they have to find
a special way to get through they were
able to go the reverse direction through
these special protein complexes now
they're going to go back into the matrix
through ATP synthase so they're going to
go back but something interesting
happens and this is really an area of
current research where people are you
know they think they know how it works
but they're not sure because you can't
just take these proteins apart and
operate them or watch them operate like
you can a regular mechanical engine
these are ultra small and they have to
be in a living system and they have to
have the right conditions and you can't
even you know it's it's hard to see
hydrogen protons these are ultra small
things that are I mean pretty much can't
see them but what happens the current
model is is as as these enter as these
go through my ATP synthase
is actually an axle so you can counter
view this as the housing and then
there's an axle and this is all just a
big protein and there's an axle and then
there's another part of the synthase
down here so you can imagine I mean this
is kind of mind-blowing such that
something this fancy is occurring on the
membranes of pretty much all living
systems cells it's not just eukaryotes
even prokaryote to do this they don't do
the mitochondria they do it in their
cellular membrane but it's a pretty neat
thing and what happens is as these go
through you can kind of imagine as water
flowing through a turbine it
mechanically causes it mechanically
causes this structure in the middle to
spin to actually spin this is the
current thinking and this thing is all
uneven it's it's not like this nice tube
you know it'll look all crazy like that
and what happens is is that an ADP
molecule let's say that this is the this
is the a part of the ADP and then you
have two phosphate groups two phosphate
groups it'll attach to one part of this
protein and maybe a phosphate will just
randomly attach to another part of this
protein just like that so right now it's
just ADP and a phosphate but as this
inner as this inner axle turns as this
inner axle turns because it's not a
symmetrical tube it has different things
sticking out that has different amounts
of atomic charge and it's going to do
it's going to it's going to play with
this outer housing right here and so as
this turns the outer housing because of
just the proteins bumping against each
other an electrical charge and whatever
else it's going to squeeze the ATP and
the the and the phosphate together to
form to actually form ATP and actually
the current thinking is it does it on
three different sites simultaneously so
as it spins around ADP and phosphate
groups kind of are show up on the you
know on the inside of this housing you
can imagine like that and I don't even
know if it's on the inside but they show
up on the housing and then as this thing
spins around it stretches and pulls on
this outer part and pushes these two
things together so it's using the energy
from this proton gradient to drive this
axle and because it's all strange it
does all these distortions on this outer
part and actually pushes the two
ATP's together so when you start off
with your 10 a nad HS it'll do it'll
provide just enough energy to do just
enough protons to put into the outer
membrane that when they go back through
our ATP synthase you can almost view our
ATP synthase motor just based on
people's observations they see that this
will produce on on a per NADH level
roughly 3 ATP's on a per fadh2 level
roughly 2 ATP's and I've said multiple
times in the videos is this kind of an
ideal that a lot of times maybe you'll
have some protons leak so they can't
their energy can't be captured properly
or maybe maybe some of these electrons
might somehow jump the gun or jump some
steps so some of the energy gets lost so
you don't always have a completely
efficient system and just so you believe
that this is actually occurring on our
membrane it's actual visual depictions
of these protons this is actual the
actual protein structure of ATP synthase
right here that is actually ATP synthase
and as you can see there's this piece
right here that holds this part that
holds that part and that part you can
kind of imagine it relatively stationary
the hydrogen comes through here the axle
gets fun and as the axle gets fun ADP
and phosphate groups that are lodged
inside this f1 part of the protein get
pushed together it's a it you have to
put energy into the reaction in order to
make them stick together but they get
pushed together by the protein itself as
this axle turns around and this axle
turns around from the energy of the
hydrogen going I don't even know what
the mechanics would look like but you
could imagine you know in my head I
imagine kind of you know you could the
simplest thing is a windmill or not a
windmill is a is maybe a is you know
some type of water turbine or maybe the
simplest thing is you know if you have
something like that on if that's what
the protein actually looks like you have
any kind of thing passing by it's going
to spin it it's going to spin it like
that and you could be more creative if
you want to change the angle of the spin
and whatnot and that's all you know
people are really still trying to
understand this at a deeper and deeper
level but for your purposes for your
purposes especially in an introductory
biology level you just have to realize
that two things are
happening in the electron transport
chain electrons are moving from the NADH
s and the fadh2s to eventually show up
and reduce the oxygen and as they do
that they're releasing energy as they go
from one molecule to another they're
going to lower energy states that energy
is used to pump hydrogen protons into
the outer compartment of the
mitochondria and then that gradient
those hydrogen protons want to get back
in into the matrix of the mitochondria
so as they go back in that drives this
ATP synthase engine which actually
produces the ATP so just like we said in
the past when you have ten of these on
average let me say this way on average
each NADH is going to produce three atps
not directly it produces enough of a
gradient of hydrogen protons to produce
three ATP's in the ATP synthase and each
fadh2 on average produces enough of a
hydrogen gradient to produce two ATP's
so if we come in with ten NADH they're
going to produce in this ideal world 30
ATP and then r2f ADH is each 2s are
going to produce 4 ATP and then if you
remember from glycolysis we had to net
ATP's
directly produced and from the Krebs
cycle we had 2 ATP's directly produced
so then you have four from glycolysis
and Krebs and that gets us once again to
our magic 38 ATP from one molecule of
glucose and now I think you have a
pretty good grasp of cellular
respiration